one of the most important applications
of conditional probability is in
analyzing the results of diagnostic
tests of uncertain reliability so let's
look at a fundamental example suppose
that I have a diagnostic test for
tuberculosis it really sounds great
because it's gonna be 99% accurate in
fact more than 99% accurate really
because here are the properties that
this test has if you have TB this test
is guaranteed to detect it and say yes
you have TB if you don't have TB 99% of
the time the the test says correctly
that you don't have TB and 1% of the
time it gets it wrong now suppose the
doctor gives you the test and the test
comes up saying that you have TB that's
kind of scary
because TV is a fact quite a serious
disease it's getting worse because there
are all of these antibiotic resistant
versions of TB now in Asia where all the
known antibiotics are not very effective
if effective at all at curing it
and this test that was 99% accurate says
I have this disease it sounds really
worrisome but in fact we can ask more
technically should you really be worried
what is the probability given that this
apparently highly accurate test says you
have TB what's the probability that you
actually have TB that's what we want to
calculate what's the probability that
you have it so in other words I want the
conditional probability of that I have
TB given that the test comes in positive
the test says yes you have TV TV um that
test positive is a big word that I won't
have room for another slide so let's
just abbreviate it by plus plus means in
green that the test said yes positive it
has you have TB okay so that's the
probability that we're trying to
calculate this conditional probability
what do we know about the test let's
translate the information we have about
the tests into the language of
conditional probability and the first
thing we said was the test is guaranteed
to get it right if you had
tbh so given that you have TB the
probability that the test will say so it
will return a positive result is one
okay given that you don't have TB the
probability that the test will say that
you do have TB is only 1 in 100 because
99% of the time it correctly says you
don't have TB and 1% of the time it says
oops you do have TB so this is what's
called the false positive rate it's
falsely claiming that you have teamed TB
when you really don't and that rate
we're hypothesizing is only 1% now what
we're trying to calculate again is the
probability that you have TB given that
the test came in positive and said you
had TB well let's look at the definition
of conditional probability the
probability that you have TB given that
the test came in positive said that said
you do is simply the the probability
that both the test comes in positive and
you have TB divided by the probability
that the test comes in positive well
using the definition of conditional
probability again this intersection this
end of having TB and the test coming and
positive is simply the probability that
the test comes in positive given that
you have TB times the probability that
you have TB now this one we know it's
one because the test is perfect if you
have TB the test is definitely going to
say positive so that lets me simplify
things nicely what I've just figured out
is the probability that you have TB
given that the test says you do is
simply the quotient of the probability
that you have TB given no other
information and the probability that the
test comes in positive well what is that
probability that the test comes in
positive how are we going to calculate
that that's the key unknown here and
we're going to use the probability rule
the profit total probability rule total
probability says that you do
don't have TB so that the way to
calculate the probability that the test
comes in positive is to look at the
probability that the test comes in
positive when you do and don't have to
be and we know those numbers so let's
look at the total probability formula
the probability that the test comes in
positive is simply the probability that
it comes in positive if you have TB
times the probability you have TB plus
the probability it comes in positive
given that you don't have TB times the
probability you don't have TB well we
know a lot of these terms
let's work them out well the probability
they the test comes in positive given
that you have TB is one and the
probability that the test comes in
positive given that you don't have TB is
1/100 that's the false positive rate we
figured out already what about the
probability that you don't have TB well
that's simply 1 minus the probability
that you do have TB now I have this nice
arithmetic formula in the probability of
TB so I wind up with a probability of TB
plus 100 minus 100 of the probability of
TB it leaves me with a hundredths plus
the ninety-nine hundredths of TB so
that's what this simplifies to the
probability that the test comes in
positive given no other information is
99 100 the probability that a person has
TB plus 1/100 will come back to this
formula well we were working on the
probability that you have TB given the
test came in positive we figured out
that it was this quotient and now I know
what the denominator is the denominator
is 99 100 times the probability of TB
plus 100th multiply numerator and
denominator through by a hundred and you
get that the probability that you have
TB given that the test says you do is a
hundred times the probability that you
have TB divided by 99 times the
probability that you have TB plus one so
let's hold that formula
notice the key unknown here is the
probability that you have to be given a
independent of the test the probability
that a random person in the population
has TB if we can figure that out or if
we can look that up then we know what
this unknown is the probability that you
have TB given that the test says you do
well what is the probability that a
person in the United imperson has TB
well there were 11,000 cases of TB
reported in 2011 according to the Center
for Disease Control in the United States
and you could assume that there's going
to be a lot of unreported cases if there
are 11,000 reported ones because a lot
of people don't even know they have the
disease
so let's estimate on that basis given
that the population of the u.s. around
350 million a billion of a million that
the probability of TB is about 110
thousand let's plug that into our
formula the probability that you have TB
given the test is positive is this
formula when I plug in one
ten-thousandth for TB I get a hundred
over 10,000 and 99 over 10,000 plus one
well now I can see the denominator is
essentially 1 its 1.0 1 and the
numerator is a hundredth and this is
basically about 1/100 in other words
it's not very likely that you have TB
because of the relatively high false
positive rate that was relatively high
of one percent that was positive rate
washed out on the the actual number of
TB cases which where the TB rate was
only 0.01 percent so that almost all of
the reports of TB were caused by the
high false positive rate and that means
that when you have a report that you've
got TB you still only have a 1 percent
chance that you actually have the TB
so the 99% accurate test was not very
useful here for you to figure out what
kind of action to take and what kind of
medicine to take her treatment to take
given that the test came in positive
with one in 100 chance the odds are you
won't do anything in which case you
could wonder why did your doctor give
you the test
well the 99 percent test sounds good we
figured out that it isn't and a hint
about why 99 percent accurate isn't
really so useful is that there's an
obvious test that's 99.99% accurate
what's the test always say no after all
the probability is only 1 in 10,000 that
you're going to be wrong and that's the
99.99% right so it sounds as though this
test is really worthless but no it's not
if you think about it a little bit oh it
will it will be useful explain that a
minute I forgot I'm getting ahead of
myself because the basic formula that we
used here was we figured out what the
probability of TB were given that the
test said you had TB in terms of the
inverse probabilities which we know that
is the probability that the test came in
positive given that you had TB this was
an example of what's a famous rule in
probability theory it's called Bayes
rule or Bayes law and this is it's just
stated in terms of arbitrary events a
and B it expresses the probability of B
given a in terms of the probability of a
given B and the probabilities of a and B
independently now I can actually never
remember this law but I read the rive it
every time I need to do it as we've done
in the previous slides it's really a
quite straightforward law to derive and
prove but let's go back to this 99%
accurate test that seemed worthless
since there was a trivial test that was
99.9% accurate but in fact it's really
helpful because it did increase the
probability that you had PB by a factor
of 100 before you took the test and
before you know anything you thought
that your probability was the same as
everybody else is about one in 10,000
now the test says the probability that
you have TB is 1 in 100 that's 100 times
larger what's the value of that well
suppose you only had
five million doses of medicine to treat
this American population of 350 million
people who should you medicate well if
you medicated a random 5 million people
out of 350 million the likelihood that
you're going to get in very many of the
real TB cases is small it's only gonna
be about 1 in 30
you'll only get about one 30th of the
cases but if you use your 5 million
doses to medicate the 3.5 million people
who would test positive under this 99%
accurate test then when you test all 350
million people you're going to get about
3.5 million who test positive you have
enough medication to treat all of them
and if you treat all of them you're
almost certain to get all of the actual
TB cases all 10,000 of them so the 99%
accurate test does have a important use
in this final setting a lot more so than
the 99.99% accurate test that simply
always said no food for thought